the newest actor to step into the Spidey
suits Tom Holland made his Marvel
Cinematic Universe debut in 2016 s
Captain America Civil War then bust in
the solo spotlight for his own film
spider-man homecoming a year later
Hollander since burst into the
mainstream establishing himself as our
still quite young geillis actor and
proven his iteration of spider-man to be
an integral part of the MCU including
2018 s Avengers infinity war despite his
Marvel movie experience however Holland
had trouble keeping it together on the
Infinity was set finding it difficult to
work with a fellow actor speaking with
hey you guys Holland revealed that he
actually had trouble acting opposite
Chris Pratt's loan in the MCU for his
guardians of the galaxy franchise
character star but don't worry about
prima donna drama on the set of infinity
war the reason for Holland strife is
actually pretty darn adorable
speaking of Prats Holland said he is so
funny he's so fun and he has such great
stories about his career and about the
industry and he's also just super
talented but it wasn't being in awe of
Pratt's sheer talent that gave Holland
trouble Pratt was simply too funny and
Holland couldn't be around him without
folding over and a fit of laughter found
it quite difficult because he would make
me laugh so much
you know and
he's the man absolutely love him not
that anyone ever dealt today but it
seems the guardians actor is just as
goofy and fun-loving when the cameras
stopped rolling as Marvel fans would
hope we can imagine that with Chris
Pratt being Chris Pratt it must have
been hard for Holland to keep a straight
face admittedly though a
fifteen-year-old kid like pizza Parker
would probably be tickled pink in the
presence of the silly star-lord so
perhaps some of Holland smirks are make
it into the film's theatrical Kurt's a
completely genuine thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love to
[Music]